hey guys I'm Alvin and we're here in the
tasty kitchen and today we're gonna be
taking a look at some of my biggest
making a big moment so let's get to it
this is 7 pounds sounds like a lot
that's because it is you know we're
gonna do these it guys because I don't
think a lot of cooking I was like did we
blend check in from scratch and do we
show that cuz I know everybody has seen
the pink paste you've seen from
McDonald's chicken nuggets and I was
like we kind of gross but I was like you
know what we're gonna do it to prove
that it is fresh may or may not look
gross to you it looks gross like skip 10
minutes of grinding meat because it took
that long to get it in batches I was
just like you know what we're not gonna
show it delicious delicious so we have
some salt of course the ground black
pepper garlic powder let's just see I
didn't try to breathe through my nose
during this that's only enough for one
chicken nugget by the way we have to do
four times that so I gave our career
break and we blend into a school I'm
just gonna make a ball this this part it
sounds gross but it feels very funny
because you're like if you have gloves
on you can't tell that you're slapping
raw chicken is like slapping jello so I
was like genuinely having a lot of fun
slapping the chicken any DJ's out there
probably a remix deck what they call a
slapper I want to say that's oh my god
whatever I say well I say these things
we got the boot it just basically looks
like the bone and then there's someone
like Photoshop has stretched it out a
little bit don't think I'd wear this
boot oh yeah this is this was awesome so
like after we fried all the Nuggets and
all the fries seeing that just like
spread in front of you like I felt as
victorious as the fanfare music we used
in this oh man our art department just
killed it with the packages these boxes
are a plus honey mustard and we also
have the good old fashioned okay so this
is like you know those like Heinz
mustard or ketchup and mustard bottles
went around the office because we have
them in our conversations and
I think we just found like four or five
and just like took them all away and
emptied it into a bowl and the rest of
the office probably didn't have ketchup
or mustard for a very long time Oh Jake
yes my guy right there
this is the mozzarella sticks and onion
rings in front of you oh my god
hope you're hungry my favorite part okay
so I told Jake beforehand I was like we
cannot bring dishonor to the family we
need to get the biggest cheese pool ever
they're gonna grab this I'm gonna grab
this we're gonna pull it and it's gonna
be amazing and I think this is one of my
favorite parts of the show oh la la this
is some kind of keeps going just kept
pulling this is unreal this tastes so
good right it actually tasted insanely
good it's like a mozzarella stick
sandwich that's exactly Jake it's a
mozzarella stick sandwich okay you're
gonna like use those onion rings I think
you could use like a steering wheel good
good some sauce on your face there Jake
ah the hundred a humle or 120 peg outlet
this was truly nerve-racking because it
was so heavy and the spatula I was using
was almost about to break it's so thin
if it cracks you're done for so this
part I was like truly like oh my god
this is a storage needs to work because
it was the final layer if that breaks
then the whole thing is over right a
hundred this little extra leg room is
gonna help we're gonna move it on to 120
it all comes down to this folks the
weight of the omelet literally was about
to break this spatula we were using yeah
so that's spatula I don't know I don't
remember where we got it I think our art
team was looking for paint supplies and
they sent me a picture they're like hey
we found this big thing do you want it
for the decoration I was like I want it
for the show come on come on out you can
do it
cool did you get okay who's gonna put
this guy in the middle because I want to
fold this Wow I'm getting nervous
reliving my own video then I know that I
did it but like it's still
nerve-wracking alright let's go oh this
was so hard oh my god I was like really
likes a cute face I want to draw a cute
face I suck so bad at art I'm really
really really bad I literally had to
practice on like paper towels and plates
like 20 times before I drew the real
face I was like here's a plate just it
and then the smile was like crooked and
I'd do it again and the one of the eyes
was bigger than the other so by the time
it just got the smile face on the
omelette I had literally had like a
plate and just like was drugged so when
he's finally faces and like wiping it
off and practicing again not the next
Picasso but definitely not the next
Picasso why is one side lopsided close
your eyes hammer this part I told her I
was making something for her she didn't
know what it was I feel you're gonna
make just that America omelet psych hit
her with that you know reverse card it's
actually not a hundred eggs 120 it's not
even showing her the omelet but as long
here no is hotter than 20 let's name
this after you middle name
Wheaties Karl week okay then she hit me
will do a reverse card and was like
we're gonna name this after your middle
name I don't remember how she found out
my middle name was but let's just say
this reaction is it 100% genuine sorry
Karl
this was fun this was violent Lucy's in
- oh my god the 100 layer dip holy moly
this was this was crazy oh my god I
don't think I could've did this episode
without Kelsey I think she brought
energy food assistance and like moral
support to make this happen this was the
hardest and heaviest thing I think we've
ever had to make on the show we
literally had to use an aquarium to do
it
it was insane we made a joke about how
in the beginning we're gonna use a fish
tank and we actually use the fish tank
this took six big guys to carry like two
feet just to put it on like a table
it was literally out of heavy I was
scared that Quentin was gonna break out
and all the stuff was gonna come out I
was like you can't have giant dip
without giant ship so we made some giant
chips okay what I told her you can try
to dip a chip into this and you can get
some out in my head i 100% knew it was
not gonna work I just wanted to see her
fail yeah see my face right here that's
the face of like I told you so I knew it
was gonna break I'm just waiting for it
but you don't know that yet yep there
you go yeah I knew that was happening
here was like two pounds of dip on that
chip I think this is a two hander I was
starving at this point and I was
genuinely really excited to eat this
because we were working so hard the
whole day to build it and I really
wanted to eat it tomorrow I actually
genuinely enjoyed it because everybody
was different and it actually tasted
really good I ate the whole thing
oh this is Maura's episode with Rea I
remember this one this one was a fun
episode oh I love this part a giant
pillow so how about I hold it up and you
can lay your head against it
it's like a memory foam this is so fun I
loved it really had been talking smack
to me about making her a giant
marshmallow for like months okay well
yeah we were like hey if it's like a
pillow wouldn't it be fun to faceplant
and I was like let's put down some saran
wrap first oh my god
faster that I think I was like yo yay if
we do back in force we could make a gif
so I was like let's just put her face in
there like four times
poaching fortune she also shares my
enthusiasm for torching and fire which
was great it literally took us 45
minutes like to torch the surface of the
marshmallow because it wasn't hot enough
so like we spent so long our fingers are
cramping from holding the blow tortoise
for so long nice final layer wait did
our editor put in a splat sound effect
when there wasn't one hold up we play
again nice I don't think hands sound
like that this was the final form of the
spatula that we almost broke in season
one and we literally got pizza peels to
get the cracker on it we needed to use -
okay that was another sound effect I did
not notice that all chance what are you
my guy what is this I'm gonna have to
have a talk with him imma give him a
raise woo well helps fun those were my
favorite moments from season 1 and
season 2 I want to know what you guys
like from those seasons cuz I'm always
curious about what you guys find
exciting so let me know in the comments
and I'll see you next time peace oh yes
[Music]